hi my name is skye and i'm 10 years old
i live in beautiful smodonia national
park in north wales and my interests are
rock climbing
[Music]
my campaign started when i started
subscribing to magazines
some magazines came in a paper envelope
unwrapped or in a potato starch bag
all environmentally friendly but some
came with like this a
plastic wrapper plastic blister
packaging
and free gifts like a squishy eyeball
so i wrote to the publishers and they
responded back
was not a great response so i started a
petition online
and shared on social media
[Music]
ten days later waitrose has stopped
selling
comics with plastic toys on the front
i hope all retailers can do the same and
then the publisher gorillas
this is not acceptable anymore there is
no planet b